[Applaudissements]
mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché oui j'ai péché car en réalité
je voulais dit j'ai pas fait une vidéo
qui ne soit pas un jour est un fossile
depuis super longtemps ou un paléo news
ça fait des plantes que j'ai pas fait un
débat engagé pénitence a fait des
plombes qu'on n'a pas fait un véritable
épisode entracte science donc voilà il
faut que je paye il faut que je fasse
pénitence et quoi de mieux pour faire
pénitence que de faire un truc mais que
j'ai vraiment pas du tout envie de faire
et s'il ya vraiment un truc que j'ai pas
du tout envie de faire c'est une
critique de sur la terre des dinosaures
parce que vraiment à vous me l'avez
demandé 1 sur la terre des dinosaures ça
y'a pas de soucis vous me l'avez demandé
sauf que je n'avais pas envie de le
faire parce que il ya déjà c'est un
effort de vulgarisation honnête et que
j'aime pas critiquer les efforts de
vulgarisation honnête
aucun vous l'auriez pas compris des
bagages et pénitence c'est le
rendez-vous de la mauvaise foi et bon
être de mauvaise foi avec des efforts de
vulgarisation honnête c'est quand même
pas c'est pas sympa
il faut et puis aussi de voilà la raison
pour laquelle j'ai pas envie de faire
sur la terre des dinosaures c'est parce
que j'aime pas les documentaires je
supporte pas les documentaires en
particulier ceux qui parlent de
paléontologie parce que je sais qu'ils
disent c'est pas qu'il dise de la merde
mais c'est juste que voilà c'est la
façon de le dire quoi et
particulièrement sur la terre des
dinosaures sur la terre des dinosaures
c'est on vous balance on vous balance un
mélange de fiction et de et de fait sans
vous dire la distinction entre les deux
sens vous dire d'où sortent les théories
sans vous dire quoi que ce soit et en
plus sur la terre des dinosaures à ceux
ci pour lui d'être un très vieux
documentaires en tous cas pour les
standards d'aujourd'hui
donc il a beaucoup d'informations qui
sont qui sont plus du tout à jour quoi
donc
donc voilà je vois pas d'ordinaire je ne
vois pas l'intérêt de faire une critique
constructive d'un effort déjà qui se
veut au net et en plus de quelque chose
qui est de relativement anciens et donc
il y aura forcément des informations qui
ne seront pas à jour donc voilà voilà
pourquoi je ne voulais pas faire sur la
terre des dinosaures et voilà pourquoi
sur la terre des dinosaures est parfait
pour des bagages et pénitence parce que
j'ai pas du tout du tout envie de le
faire et que vous aimez me voir souffrir
alors voilà je vais me taper sur la
terre des dinosaures magnifique
reportage où on va se laisser bercer par
la voix d'andré dussollier à travers les
millions d'années donc voilà là je le
laisse je le laisse nous nous faire
remonter le temps je vous laisse aussi
admirer ce magnifique dailymotion donc
voilà oui je regarde sur dailymotion et
dailymotion maintenant apparemment doit
se prostituer
on dirait
pour pour faire concurrence à youtube en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce qui a
l'air de se prendre de se produire mais
bref voilà donc je le regarde sur
dailymotion ça permet de le voir en
français et ça ça permet aussi de de
combler ma radinerie parce que non je
n'ai pas acheté le reportage
faut pas déconner voilà donc là ils nous
font un petit résumé de tout ce qui va
se produire pendant la série la cdu
c'est du teasing donc on va pas non plus
va pas se mettre à critiquer les
passages de teasing donc ça remonte dans
le temps ça remonte dans le temps donc
le buzz c'est le premier épisode donc
c'est l'épisode qui parle du trias
normalement mais ça y va nous le
confirme et voilà il ya 220 millions
d'années
voilà déjà ils appellent ça ère
secondaire
attendez attendez donc déjà ils
appellent ça ère secondaire
bon on appelle ça le mésozoïque
maintenant et je pense que même à
l'époque alors je me rappelle plus de
quand date le reportage met même à
l'époque je suis à peu près sûr que ça
s'appelait déjà le mésozoïque mais bref
on a vu passer un crâne je suis curieux
de voir ce que c'est comme crâne parce
que ça c'est ça c'est quand même un
crâne du genre que je connais pas ce
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc est ce
que c'est censé être un herrera aux
russes parce que si c'est censé être un
nra zo russe c'est raté
voilà le crâne des réseaux rue ça
ressemble pas du tout à ça hop skull ce
qui évidemment quand on tape quand on
tape herrera zaurus on tombe sur des
reconstructions c'est assez fou
d'ailleurs de constater à quel point le
la paléontologie ou du moins la
vulgarisation paléontologique est
quasiment dictée par les par les pales
et aux artistes
vous voyez raso russa a rien à voir avec
ce truc là je sais pas ce que c'est
censé être ce truc là parce que là enfin
le problème c'est que ce truc n'a ni
queue ni tête si ça c'est censé être
lors bits et ça c'est sans cesse d'une
fausse orbitaire alors elles sont où les
fausses post orbitaire quoi le dire si
c'est censé être un crâne darcos or je
vois pas de je vois pas où sont les
fausses temporal les fausses et des
fausses temporal y est censé y en avoir
2 6 et un crâne d'arc aux orres la
volaille en à une là il y en a une seule
dessus à l'arrière de l'orbiteur et la
fo santé orbitaire ici là je vois la
narine la fo santé orbitaire une orbite
mais je vaux pas de fausse temporal donc
je sais pas ce qu'on est censés regarder
la ici ce gran n'existe pas ce crâne
n'existe officiellement voilà nous
venons d'entrer dans le trias donc sur
le thème de cette vidéo du premier
épisode 2 sur la terre des dinosaures
voilà et on est déjà sur des conneries
et ça ne fait que commencer 3 minutes 48
donc oui je disais le vulgarisation
scientifique en paléontologie semble
être dicté par les paléo artiste c'est
marrant en fait si les palais aux
artistes en vogue des crêtes qu'une
reconstruction est honnête
alors ça veut dire que cette
reconstruction elle va être conservé par
les par les puristes on va dire alors
qu'au final
au final elle peut s'être heureux
constitution peut être scientifiquement
complètement fausse je finis juste le
thème que j'ai abordé tout à l'heure il
ya 2 minutes et c'est notamment le cas
du spinosaures quoi parce que
spinosaures spinosaurus skelton voilà la
nouvelle reconstruction du spinosaurus
donc celle ci voilà le spinosaurus
quadrupèdes
c'est un amalgame de spécimens c'est
même pas un seul spécimen quoi c'est un
amalgame d'une dizaine de spécimens et
je crois si j'arrive à si j'arrive à
trouver cette image voilà c'est celle là
donc chaque couleur correspond à un
spécimen différents donc on est bien
d'accord que le fait que ce spinosaurus
sera constitué comme quadrupèdes
ça vient surtout du fait que ses bras
sans vachement plus longue ses jambes
oui mais ses bras n'appartiennent pas au
même spécimens que ses jambes c'est pas
la même bestioles les bras et les jambes
de spinosaurus alors de ou alors de où
vous vous nous affairer qu'il était
quadrupèdes alors que si ça se trouve ça
c'est des jambes de juvéniles et ça
c'est des bras d'adulte
donc voilà mais parce que les paléo
artiste trouve ça plutôt classe de
maître spinosaurus à quatre pattes et
ben du coup et que ça a été publiée dans
nature et ben du coup ben voilà on finit
avec un spinosaurus à quatre pattes
alors que je vais dire ça ça se voit que
les jambes et les bras vont pas ensemble
mais bref
donc voilà c'est juste c'était mon mini
coup de gueule du début je râle déjà
voilà mais au moins c'est dit on
continue avec sur la terre des
dinosaures et ses magnifiques d'ici 90
mes favoris bon je vais pas râler sur l'
usage du mot reptiles on comprend bien
que on comprend bien que reptile est un
amalgame du moa mignotte et s'oxyder que
bon il
voilà c'est juste que soro petite
personne connaît donc on va pas
commencer en bété peuple avec de la
terminologie amniotes et europe cite
personne connaît tout le monde connaît
reptiles donc même si ça crée un peu de
confusion entre les deux c'est pas non
plus le la fin du monde
et oui je les dis
alors là on était attendait parce que
tout à l'heure il a dit 120 millions
d'années de 120 millions d'années
voilà donc tout à l'heure et d'idées 220
millions d'années
enfin il y à 220 millions d'années
maintenant ils ont changé d'unité alors
c'est un peu chaud donc oui ça c'est le
titre me la remet la dette remet la date
regardez tout à l'heure n'avait miliani
roggo et maintenant on à bissy donc
c'est la même date
mais comme s'est présentée de deux
façons différentes charges herman
confuse en voilà et on n'est qu'à quatre
minutes 50
donc voilà usage du mot reptiles dans le
sens amniotes puisque ce sont des dt
rapide la flore toujours grande perdante
de ces reconstructions fin des
reportages sur la la flore c'est
toujours la grande perdante des
reportages sur les sur la paléontologie
parce qu'on préfère utiliser des plantes
moderne qui ont une vague affinités avec
des plantes qui date d'il ya 220
millions d'années plutôt que de faire
des petits modèles de ces plantes telles
qu'elles étaient réellement il ya 220
millions d'années donc voilà donc les
plantes elles passent pour des fossiles
vivants quoi c'est génial on va
peut-être que ça la limite c'est une
reconstruction allez je vous la corde
éventuellement voilà mais on préfère
privilégier et décors naturels préfère
privilégier des décors naturels même si
en l'occurrence il montre une flore qui
n'est pas du trias
donc le sait le physique en train de
chasser
1 1-10 pneus est donc évidemment on est
évidemment on est au début des années
2000 voire fin des années 90 avec ce
reportage donc les bras de celle au
physique ne sont pas dans la bonne
position à l'est les paumes devrait être
tourné vers l'intérieur
là c'est la position jurassic park un
des bras donc les bras devrait
normalement être tournés vers
l'intérieur mais encore une fois c'est
plus un problème d'époque qu'un problème
de qu'un problème de véritablement
scientifique
je suis pas sûr que c'est le physique
s'était retrouvé avec des contenus
stomacaux qui indiquait qu'il était
piscivores je suis presque même sûr du
contraire
et surtout et surtout c'est le physique
évidemment et reconstituer sans plume
parce qu'à l'époque c'était pas classe
représenter les dinosaures avec des
plumes c'était pas du tout à la mode
mais bon encore une fois c'est comme
j'ai dit c'est vraiment cet effet de la
communication scientifique est
totalement dictée par les paléo artiste
si les palais aux artistes de la fin des
années 90 début des années 2000
reconstituer les dinosaures sans plumes
les dinosaures n'avait pas de plumes
sauf que comme maintenant ils se sont
mis à leur mettre des plumes et ben du
coup ils ont des plumes voilà alors ça
je crois que c'est censé être déplacé
ria ce
c'est bien ça donc place sérieuse plus
plat sérias donc là ce qui me choque
aussi c'est que place à yas cela il est
reconstruit avec ses gros truc là sauf
que place sériès normalement il a pas de
défense placées est ce si vous regardez
le crâne en fait c'est pas des défenses
et ainsi nos dons qui est pas classique
un plat cerias voyez c'est pas les
défenses qui forment ces procès ces
processus en fait ce sont des procès ce
sont des basses et de l'os quoi en fait
ce sont les processus maxillaire canini
forme qui forme qui remplace les
défenses donc plat sérias n'a pas
vraiment de défense c'est pas comme ça
un plat sérias il n'a pas de défense en
fait il a des processus canini forme
très développés qui remplace les
défenses donc ça déjà c'est faux et ne
vous imaginez pas que c'est une petite
erreur les défenses ces deux là dedans
alors que le ce cap-là sérias en fait
c'est de l'eau ce purin donc c'est pas
une petite erreur pour le coup voilà on
est quand on n'est qu'à 8 minutes 30
j'ai déjà repéré tellement d'erreurs que
enfin des erreurs des as we puis voilà
aïe aïe aïe
le synode honte alors 6 92 sur la terre
des dinosaures
sinon tu walking with dinosaurs c'est
normalement un tri naxos dons ou du
moins c'est très très fortement inspiré
de trignac selon et trine naxos dont
mesdames et messieurs il n'a pas du tout
vécu en même temps que place arias il
vivait il ya 250 millions d'années pas
il y à 220 millions d'années
donc là on est sur un gouffre de 30
millions d'années 30 millions d'années
c'est grosso modo c'est grosso modo la
distance qui ne s'est pas enfin il ya 30
millions d'années notre plus proche
parent ressemblait à un petit singe quoi
30 millions d'années ça nous ramène
quand même à l'oligocène goy souci
mignon c'est mignon est ce qu'il ya un
endroit où s'est dit exactement quel
sino dont ils ont utilisé parce que ça
c'est complètement la morphologie d'un
tri naxos dont il ya 220 millions
d'années à la limite vous aviez des pro
b nonya tiens vous avez dessine au cna
tu mets les six naudinat avait la tête
beaucoup plus large l'arrière de la tête
était beaucoup plus large que ça chez
les sea dogs nat et chez les pros bagdad
les problèmes menottes étaient
globalement beaucoup plus petit a parlé
treaty l'aude anti démêler treated aux
antilles n avait pas du tout ce profil
là donc ça c'est totalement
c'est totalement la morphologie d'un tri
nations qu'ils ont utilisés pour ça et
en plus les treaty l'aude ont été
complètement avait des membres
complètement érigé ce qui n'est pas le
cas de leurs synodaux et un bon bah
voilà là vous voyez il est bien
identifié comme tri naxos dont donc bon
alors à la limite je leur fais cadeau du
fait qu'ils ont utilisés synodaux et
patrie naxos dont ce qui est ce qui fait
qu'ils y échappent
1 il y échappent de justesse mais le
design c'est qu'on s'est totalement
celui de three naxos donc être inac ce
dont il a vécu il ya 250
250 millions d'années entre 252 et 250
millions d'années et pas du tout il y à
220 millions d'années quoi il ya 220
millions d'années ça devrait ainsi
donner at ou un problème n'était pas du
tout ainsi nous donne basale comme tri
naxos dont voilà reconstitue avec des
moustaches évidemment alors que
alors que c'est pas le cas laiterie
naxos dont on ne devait pas avoir de
moustache si longtemps whiskers il ne
devait pas avoir des moustaches parce
que alors on va peut-être plus tôt
marqué maxi larry canal ne devait pas
avoir de moustache parce que le seul
intérêt des moustaches c'est de pouvoir
capter ces deux c'est de bouger
voilà de faire des mouvements sur les
côtés voilà si vous regardez ses
moustaches
c'est magnifique moustache leur seul
intérêt c'est de bouger et en bougeant
elles vont servir d'organe tactile or le
tri naxos dont il avait ça ils avaient
ils avaient ils avaient le nerf pour in
qui sert normalement à énerver les
moustaches qui était complètement
enfermé dans un canal au ce donc s'il y
avait vraiment des moustaches connecter
à ce n'est rv ses moustaches ne pouvais
pas bouger donc elle ne servait à rien
donc il y avait certainement pas de
moustache et trignac secondes voilà donc
et aujourd'hui on le sait
on le sait depuis même les années 60
d'ailleurs que ce canal là ils
empêchaient totalement les il
empêcherait totalement les moustaches
d'être utile donc s'il y avait des
moustaches et rédactionnelle ne servait
à rien et surtout elle ne serait pas
perche et la sueur sur une petite bosse
de chair comme ça à trignac ce dont il
n'avait pas du tout ce qu'il fallait ou
là ouais alors là ça va beaucoup trop
vite on revient un peu en arrière on
revient un peu en arrière merci voilà
donc notre magnifique tri naxos dont là
vous voyez il a des petites bosses des
petites bosses de chair sur le côté de
la tête
voilà on va aller voir la réveille toi
petite ride accident voilà donc là il ya
ces petites bosses de chair sur le côté
de la tête et qui bouge en plus voilà
ils les font bouger donc ça c'était
impossible
c'était impossible puisqu'il n'y avait
pas de chair il n'ya pas le ja parce
qu'il faut à cet endroit là pour
l'insertion des muscles qui font cette
chaire sur le sur l'animal et en plus
ils leur ont fait 1
en plus ils leur ont fait une truffe et
ça c'est pareil il y avait certainement
pas de truffes chetrit naxos dont fâcher
les chez la plupart des sino dont tu as
parlé plus dérivés entre eux comme
brasil y therion mais là déjà 220
millions d'années
c'est trop tôt pour brésil y terium donc
voilà donc 220 millions d'années il n'y
avait pas de sinnoh d'onde avec une
truffe hachée désole la truffe des il y
avait il y avait même probablement une
séparation osseuse entre les deux
narines donc comme chez un lézard par
exemple donc là en fait il y avait plus
probablement des écailles sur le côté du
visage et pas tellement ou de la peau
nue mais pas de valve a pas de chair et
encore moins des poils voilà étape
suivante
l'allaitement
regardez-moi ça or voilà là vous venez
d'entendre pendant les trois premiers
mois ils se nourriront haugland allait
que leur mère porte au ventre c'est
exactement ce qui est dit là au moins je
fais pas d'inférence sur quelle espèce
il s'agit s il s'agit bien de tri naxos
dont alors ils ont tout faux nom
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça là on vient
d'entendre pendant les trois premiers
mois ils vont salle était aux mamelles
de l'heure de leur maman et voilà d'où
sort cette information
vous ne savez pas je ne sais pas et je
suis sûr que même ne le savent pas même
ceux qui ont fait le reportage ne le
savent pas c'est pour ça que je ne
supporte pas ce genre de reportage c'est
parce qu'ils te balance cette
information pendant trois mois ils vont
être nourri aux glandes à l'aide leurs
mamans ça sort de nulle part
ils l'ont inventé ils l'ont inventé ce
n'est pas une information alors que
c'est censé être un docu fiction on nous
balance des trucs comme étant des
documents alors qu'en fait c'est de la
fiction c'est bien ça le problème que
j'ai avec ces [ __ ] de docu fiction
c'est que oui on me dit voilà c'est en
gros ils balancent des conneries et moi
on me regarde en me disant oui mais
c'est un docu fiction donc il ya de la
fiction mais dans ta gueule
il ya docu avant fiction [ __ ] arrête
avec tes conneries de docu fiction c'est
un documentaire avant une fiction et je
veux savoir d'où vient la documentation
d'où vient la partie documentaire et
comment la distinguer de la fiction là
je peux pas on vient de me balancer il
met trois mois alors si je suis pas si
je suis pas moi-même
paléontologues bas en gros je sais pas
et je prends ça pour argent comptant je
ne dis bah oui bah on doit avoir des
bonnes raisons de dire ça non on a zéro
bonne raison de dire ça on a zéro bonnes
raisons on n'a aucune idée
on sait même pas s'il pondent des oeufs
on pense que oui parce que parce que les
mots notres m donc ornithorynque et qui
tenait pondent des oeufs et que du coup
ça semble être l'étape
enfin ça semble être la condition
primitive chez des mammifères mais voilà
dans l'absolu on n'a jamais trouvé duff
de 6,90
donc on sait même pas s'il pondent des
oeufs alors comment vous croyez qu'on
sait quoi de la période de gestation de
ces animaux on n'en sait rien du tout on
a peut-être et je dis bien peut-être des
des preuves de soins parentaux voit la
passe et encore il ya elles ont été
découvertes il ya que très récemment
on a peut-être éventuellement des
preuves de soi parentaux depuis les
années 50 on a découvert quelques tri
naxos dont et quelques gars les eaux
russes avec des
où il y avait des associations de
juvéniles avec des parents mais ça peut
encore être du pain en face à peut être
les parents qui squattent les terriers
des enfants ou linverse les enfants qui
squattent les terriers des parents et
pas forcément des soins parentaux et il
ya encore très récemment on a trouvé à
un cahier materion l'ancien je peux vous
le montrer parce qu'il va y avoir des
jolies images on a trouvé un cahier
materion avec une portée de 30 de petits
alors en plus voilà voilà donc ça c'est
la représentation graphique artistique
j'ai envie de dire de la mer et de la
taille du crâne
chez les petits donc il ya trente deux
petits ou 28 jeu c'est plus une
trentaine de petits et voilà et ça ça
ils ont été retrouvés ensemble ce qu'il
veut même pas forcément dire qu'ils ont
ce qui veux même pas forcément dire
qu'ils ont qu'elle s'occupait d'eux mais
disons que voilà après le fossile
lui-même est pas impressionnant du tout
donc je préfère vous montrez de
reconstitution comme ça voilà au moins
c'est très visuel
mais voilà on a retrouvé le fossile
d'une d'un cahier n'da terium adultes
donc qui est ainsi 90 avec des cayes nta
terium juvénile qui sont suffisamment
petit pour être des nouveaux des nouveau
nés est d'ailleurs ses nouveau nés ont
des dents fonctionnel donc l'allaitement
montcuq allaitement montcuq chez les
synodaux l'allaitement il y en avait pas
chez les 6 90 parce que les petits
cahiers n'da terium là ils ont des dents
fonctionnel alors peut-être que ça
n'exclut pas qu'il ait eu des glandes
capable de fabriquer du lait peut-être
que ces glandes servait à autre chose
chez les signaux dont tu attention me
faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit
par contre l'action d'allaiter elles
n'existaient certainement pas chez et
6,90
il y avait peut-être des glandes aller
et pas des mamelles parce que ça c'est
pareil [ __ ] les votes étaient des
mamelles quoi enfin je veux dire ils
sont alignés comme ça la regarde et les
ont laissés complètement inspirée d'une
portée de chatons en train de téter des
mamelles
non il n'y avait pas deux mamelles chez
dessine au don d'un il ya déjà pas deux
mamelles chez les mots notres m alors
encore moins chez les signaux dont les
mots notres m y sécrètent ils ont un
gros patch de peau sur le ventre et il
sécrète du lait à travers de ce patch de
peau ils n'ont pas deux mamelles alors
encore moins les signaux dont je suis
désolé donc mamelles montcuq allaitement
montcuq glande à l'est pourquoi pas mais
elle servait pas elle servait pas à
allaiter
voilà peut-être qu'elle servait juste à
distribué delà de commandes hier deux
des matières grasses pour humidifier les
oeufs pourquoi pas ou pour humidifier le
nid ou pour marquer son territoire je
sais pas à quoi elle devait servir voilà
c'est ce qu'on appelle une prêt
habitation ou pré adaptation
éventuellement même si j'aime pas trop
le mot mais bon voilà
bref c'est pas c'est pas un joli mot je
trouve mais bref voilà donc tous à la
connerie sur connerie sur connerie et on
peut pas faire la différence entre ce
qui est conneries et ce qui ne l'est pas
voilà vous êtes obligés de leur faire
confiance et de vous dire bahreïn doit y
avoir des preuves quelque part babouins
je suis désolé je veux qu'on me les
montre
merde voilà un faux pas me faire chier
avec les sino donc faut pas me faire
chier avec les signaux dont tu en voilà
vous voulez voir des glandes mammaires
il y en a plein en dessous bienvenue sur
dailymotion mais ça non pas de glandes
mammaires ici glande mammaire oui oui
glande mammaire non non glande mammaire
oui oui glande mammaire non non ça
suffit ça me fout les glandes
ah voilà et alors j'ajouterai
j'ajouterai parce qu'en plus celui là
c'est moi qui les fais voilà là vous
avez un article qui s'appelle le plat
vous avez sur richard gates
internet devient fou vous avez surveille
sort du gatt un article qui s'appelle
soins parentaux opportunisme ou
opportunisme chez les
chez les ch'ti naudon dutriat sic sud
africain où vous avez cette magnifique
figures dont je suis l'auteur en fait
cette figure ce qu'elle vous montre je
sais pas si je vais arriver à l'affiché
correctement évidemment non évidemment
que non parce que sinon ce ne serait pas
drôle
on va essayer de l'affiché correctement
voilà c'est à dire que dans cet article
là je casse même la nuque à l'idée même
de soins parentaux chessy 90 parce que
vous voyez ça c'est le nombre de petits
par en fait on a un registre fossile de
bébés associés à des adultes chez les
sino d'hondt
comme je voulais dis donc il ya kalenda
terium c'est ce point là il ya quelques
tri naxos don égal et au russe s'est
tous ces points là il ya des langues
berdja aussi donc il ya pas mal de 6,90
dont des adultes ont été retrouvés avec
des petits sauf que quand on regarde la
taille des petits et le nombre des
petits en fonction du enfin non quand on
compare la taille des petits donc cet
axe là en fonction du nombre de petits
associés aux adultes
c'est ce nombre là bas en fait on
constate qu'il ya une chute drastique du
nombre de petits quand les petits
grandissent
donc en gros à 5 % de la taille adulte
vous avez 32 petits enfin une trentaine
de petits c'est le sait ce qu'on a chez
kalenda terium et à 30 % d' de la taille
adulte donc un tiers de la croissance il
n'en reste plus que quatre en moyenne
chez les il reste plus que quatre
juvénile et évidemment les adultes il en
reste plus qu'à mai
voyez c'est le ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'en gros s'il y avait soit parental il
était à chier ce soit parental parce
qu'on part de 32 petits et plus agrandi
et moi y en a voilà pour qu'au final il
reste plus que quatre que quatre petits
alors qu'ils ont grandi qu alors qu'ils
sont qu'à un tiers de leur croissance en
gros donc si soins parental il ya chez
les sino dont tu n'étais pas bon mais
alors pas bon du tout bref on continue
on remarquera tout de même que la peau
est nu je veux dire j'ai crise et sur
les poils voilà moi pour moi y avait pas
de poils j'écrivais sur les poils mais
faut quand même admettre que le reste de
la peau est nu et pas écailleuse et ça
apparemment c'est plutôt vrai voilà
si on alors y'a pas de pot préserver de
sinnoh d'hondt
hélas mais je sais pas si je vais
arriver à vous la trouvez cette image
oui elle y est merci à pia viglietti qui
est qui est une chercheuse en
paléontologie sud africaine et qui a
posté cette photo sur twitter même si
elle est faible résolution elle est bien
quand même
elle est suffisante donc voilà on n'a
qu'une seule
on n'a qu'un seul vrai beau fossiles
d'empreintes de pau pour les thérapies
site donc la grande famille qui inclut
les sino donc mais aussi lady synodaux
comme plat cerias et 7 cette momie
basset ali strause aux russes donc c'est
cette saleté là ce truc moche qui vivait
au trias c'est un dc nos données et on
n'a qu'une seule momie et cette momie à
la peau nue alors on sait pas si c'est
parce qu'il a perdu ses poils en en se
décomposant ou s'il était effectivement
inconnu mais disons que le meilleur truc
qu'on est jusqu'à présent comme fossiles
de pot de terre abside c'est ce liste
rose aux russes alors là vous avez la
tête avec les deux yeux là il ya même
les yeux brillaient licence est
dégueulasse on a l'impression de l'avoir
devant soi c'est répugnant
voilà vous avez toute la peau ici vous
avez vous avez les quatre pattes à bien
articuler magnifique donc
donc ils ont quand même il avait quand
même vu venir j'ai envie de dire la
découverte de sinistrose aux riches
parce que ça ça a été publié en fin
officiellement ça n'a été publié qu'en
2014 la photo avait probablement été
publiés par pia avant ça voilà 2011
apparemment d'après ce que je comprends
d'après ce que je lis dans la légende
l'a donc voilà elle a publié déjà la
photo en 2011 mais disons que c'était de
toute façon pas connu à l'époque où ils
ont fait le reportage quoi le mal si nos
dont tu ne chasse que la nuit d'où tu
sors ça voilà et vous pouvez faire ça
avec toutes les phrases quasiment toutes
les phrases de ce genre de docu fiction
comme sur la terre des dinosaures c'est
d'où tu sors ça d'où tu sors cette
information le mal si l'aude on ne
chasse que la nuit beaune ont
probablement patrie naxos dont non trine
axes dont il était suffisamment gros
pour être dits urnes
il n'avait pas forcément besoin d'être
nocturne il pouvait chasser des petits
vertébrés le jour ce n'était pas un
problème
un suivant par contre il faisait
effectivement des terriers ça on a dit
on a des beaux fossiles de tri nations
qui ont été découverts dans des terriers
et il n'a pas d'oreilles ça aussi je
suis d'accord n'a pas de pavillons
auditifs
parce que même les mots notres m non
plus n'ont pas de pavillons auditifs
le pavillon auditifs c'est quelque chose
qui a paru chez les mammifères
therrien donc marsupiaux placentaire et
les trucs qui en sont proches parents la
plus vieille preuve de la plus vieille
preuve d'horace espino l'espèce je crois
qu'ils datent du crétacé de pavillons
auditifs devrais je dire voilà nos plats
sérieuse qui n'avaient pas de défense
normalement et qui l'a emmené en des
immenses et orienté vers l'avant en plus
après il faut rendre à césar ce qui est
à césar sur la terre des dinosaures ça a
été un des premiers reportages a quand
même nous montrer une enfin à pas nous
montrer les mêmes 4,4 à pas nous montrer
les mêmes quatre images en boucle parce
qu'avant la sur la terre des dinosaures
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez pour
ceux qui sont assez vieux pour s'en
rappeler mais avant sur la terre des
dinosaures on avait quand même les
reportages avait tendance à faire genre
deux minutes de clips avec des
reconstructions en 3d ou pas en 3d
d'ailleurs des fois c'était des
animatroniques et genre on nous passe et
on nous faisait un commentaire de 20
minutes en ne passant en boucle les
mêmes deux minutes de clips dégueulasse
généralement donc ways sur la terre des
dinosaures a eu au moins ça pour lui d
effectivement de au moins quand il nous
faisait un reportage de 30 minutes mais
on a un vrai 36 minutes d'imagés
inédites et pas juste les mêmes deux
minutes reboucler pendant pendant je ne
sais combien de temps donc faut rendre à
césar ce qui est à césar au moins au
moins sur la terre des dinosaures nous a
sortis de ce cycle infernal de des
boucles de reconstruction dégueulasse
donc le post au sus
alors le post au sus il ya une grosse
il ya une grosse grosse contreverse
voilà c'est le mot que j'ai cherché une
grosse grosse controverse sur était-il
bipèdes ou quadrupèdes 1
alors apparemment voilà vous voyez la
sueur sur la reconstruction du squelette
il ya ceux qui le reconstitue
quadrupèdes il ya ceux qui le
reconstitue bipèdes donc à et
apparemment le petit crâne du début
c'était peut-être pas à ne s'était
peut-être pas un nra zo russe ça avait
apparemment la prétention d'être un pro
stock us
si vous vous rappelez du crâne
dégueulasse au début on est à combien on
est onze minutes 2 donc j'essaie de me
rappeler de 11 minutes 2 si vous vous
rappelez du petit crâne dégueulasse du
début qui ne ressemblait à rien va-t-on
de retrouver voilà on est on est revenu
au début voilà voyez là cette espèce de
crête là sur le sommet apparemment ça a
la prétention d'être la crête de post
sucu ce comme vous voyez le problème
reste toujours que voilà vous avez
l'oeil ici là fo santé orbitaire ici
donc le ici la faune santé orbitaire ici
oui mais problème où sont les fausses
postant port alain les deux fosses
temporel voilà elles sont pas là donc ça
reste un énorme problème
bref on retourne à 11 minutes et des
avec notre postaux subus donc mais
postaux circus il ya une grosse
controverse et d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
où on en est maintenant on peut vérifier
ça rapidement sur wikipédia mais c'est
pareil c'est pas un gros problème pour
le reportage lui-même à l'époque postaux
sucu s'était déjà été reconstituée
quadrupède et je sais pas juste si
maintenant voilà la très petite taille
des membres antérieurs par rapport aux
membres postérieurs et les très petites
mains donc c'est vrai qu'il a des toutes
petites mains si vous regardez c'est
vraiment assez
c'est ouf les mesures de vertèbres
suggère que post sucu ch était peut-être
bipèdes
voilà mais bon c'est pas c'est pas un
gros problème je veux dire à l'époque
c'était pas connue en fin du mois je
crois pas que c'était connu vérifier
voilà la source et de 2013 voilà
la source que site wikipédia c'est 2013
à parme voilà postaux sur cuche qui
chassent placer aia ce total adaptateur
post su ce qu'ils sachent qu'ils
chassent place arias est c'est dur à
dire les gars ça a l'air d'être
relativement crédible
bon à l'époque on gérait mal les
collisions aussi sur les 20 sur les
trucs en 3d donc ils avaient recours à
tout un tas d'artefacts d'artifice pour
pour ne pas nous montrer les les
contacts
pété nos eaux russes wesh ma gueule
péter nos zaurus jeu même pas sûr pété
innocent russe webb a évidemment dû
couler une page wikipédia vu qu'il est
connu à ce point là donc péter nos eaux
russes t ros hors du trias sic donc là
l'huile et du bonheur au moins pour
avoir rencontré place arias et c'est un
des plus anciens un ptérosaure vivait-il
en amérique du nord
non il vivait en italie les trois
fossiles ont été trouvés en italie en
italie on n'a pas trouvé de place et
arias en tout cas pas que je sache donc
là il a ça se passait en arizona
il n'y a pas de péter nos eaux russes en
arizona voilà donc encore une fois des
crocs raccourci mes bons amis des gros
raccourci celui là il est quasiment égal
à ambühl hausse et us je sais pas si
vous vous rappelez mais il ya sur la
terre des monstres disparu sur enfin je
crois que c'est sur la terre des
monstres disparus ou sur la terre des
géants je ne sais plus où on voit le où
on voit l'ambulance et tu sais où on
voit les ancêtres des chevaux et où on
voit le
le gast ornis et tout ça avant donc
quasiment tous dans le dans le truc
c'est la faune de messel sauf ambulance
et husky on sait pas pourquoi se trouve
à mme hessel c'est à dire en allemagne
alors qu'on l'a jamais trouvé ailleurs
que que en inde au pakistan
quoi donc voilà ils font des gros gros
gros raccourci pour que tous pour que
tout se trouve au même endroit je crois
pas que ce soit le critique à ce point
que péter nos eaux russes se promène à
côté d'un plat sérias un bon au moins on
ne néglige pas les des invertébrés ça
c'est bien
après on nous montre une libellule
moderne ça c'est moins bien
sans transition partie 2 quasiment
coupée au milieu de la phrase on
retrouve notre péter nos eaux russes le
maréchal péter norris en train de
prendre son bain regardez ça s'il est
pas mignon
donc apparemment il disait qu' il ya une
sécheresse qui n'a pas plu depuis des
mois donc c'est possible puisque n'ont
rien c'est une période très sèche
comparé aux carnières pendant lequel il
y a eu là ce qu'on appelle l'événement
pluviales car niant c'est à dire des
pluies torrentielles enfin il ya une
excursion de l'isotope du carbone des
isotopes du carbone qui font penser que
éventuellement cette excursion a été
causé par un événement pluviales
important donc voilà des pluies
torrentielles pendant plusieurs millions
d'années au moins pendant un million
d'années durant le quart n'y est donc la
période suivante il ya 220 millions
d'années le nom rien on se dirige vers
l'extinction trias on se dirige vers
l'extraction
de la limite trias jurassique et du coup
le le climat ce sarid hi-fi donc voilà
ça ça ça semble assez assez intuitif on
va dire oui une place sérias les places
sérias avec leur défense qui ne sont pas
des défenses qui sont censés être des
processus maxillaire et ben non
justement pas la défense d'un plat
sérias son processus son processus
maxillaire c'est de l'os c'est pas une
défense
ah ça c'est intéressant donc la riposte
organisée du troupeau de placer arias ça
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas mal donc
jusqu'à quel point jusqu'à quel point on
peut on peut avoir confiance en sa voilà
dans la mesure où il nous montre aucune
preuve basse et c'est quand même c'est
quand même une question intéressante
alors les places et ria s'ils font
partie d'une famille de dix synodaux
qu'on appelle les canes meyer y forme et
les canes meyer y forme on a des preuves
qu'il vivait en troupeau alors je sais
pas au niveau des empreintes de pas si
on a vraiment trouvé des empreintes de
pas de dissin aux hommes de cette époque
qui sont suffisamment bien alignées pour
qu'on puisse dire qu'elles appartiennent
à un troupeau mais par contre je sais
qu'on a trouvé ce qu'on appelle des
latrines commune donc des latrines
commune cdd bas écouteurs on va vous
montrer soir tout de suite voilà on va
faire une petite recherche donc alors
ces communes hall latrines dicillo dont
tu là donc on a trouvé des latrines
commune et alors là c'est formidable
parce que ça a été publiée dans la revue
nature vous voyez on est sur un
night-shop dot com
nature dotcom scientifique report donc
prestigieuse revue dans laquelle on
publie sur les latrines commune qui qui
donne des preuves de
devis grégaire chez les méga herbivores
du trias donc les latrines communes se
sont littéralement des gros tas de merde
donc voilà ces personnes font un article
dans nature à propos d'un gros tas de
merde oui mais un gros tas de merde très
intéressant puisqu'il est fossilisés et
ce gros tas de merde donc il appartient
à des cas de meyer y forment donc des
proches parents deux places et arias
vous voyez c'est ça c'est les crottes
voici les magnifiques crottes fossilisés
des coprolithe est donc ce gros tas de
merde fossilisés bien ils montrent qu'en
fait les cas de mayari forme il faisait
pas kaka de façon complètement aléatoire
ils allaient tous au même endroit pour
chier et ça ça
ainsi un comportement qu'on retrouve
chez des herbivores chez des herbivores
moderne qui vivent troupeau je passerai
tous les arts vivants moderne qui vivant
en troupeaux mais sonne c'est un
comportement qui ne se retrouvent que
chez les herbivores moderne qui vivent
troupeau ou du mois avec un certain
niveau de vie sociale donc voilà les
gros tas de merde fossilisés ça aide
ça montre qu'il y avait une certaine
forme de vie sociale chez les cadres
meyer y forme et ça c'est quand même la
classe
voilà des publications sur des gros tas
de merde dans nature's donc jusqu'à quel
point on peut dire que c'est réaliste de
voir des déplacés arias s'aligner pour
se défendre
ça va ça va c'est pas trop c'est pas
trop c'est pas trop kaka on va dire
c'est pas trop mal disons que c'est
raisonnable étant donné qu'on sait
qu'ils vivaient en troupeau la soie
parental de nouveaux soit parental chez
sino d'onde pour lesquels les preuves
comme je les dis sont plutôt éparses
sont même plutôt contradictoire en
réalité un donc le mal dont on a dit
qu'il chassait la nuit maintenant ils
chassent le jour voilà parce que là il
fait pas nui je suis désolé donc de quoi
de qui se moque t'on
moi je parlais justement des comptes des
contenus stomacaux ddc le physique je
crois pas qu'on ait jamais trouvé de
sinnoh d'hondt dans les contenus
stomacaux death et l'office
regardez là on voit bien la taille du
tri nations
enfin du synodaux de comparer aux c'est
l'office veut dire il est gigantesque ce
tri nations
donc déjà déjà c'est trop gros pour un
tri naxos dont mais en plus
ouais enfin dans l'arizona à cette
époque là à part à part d'être utile aux
dons idées comme cai nta terium que je
vous ai montré tout à l'heure il n'y
avait pas des masses de il n'y avait pas
des masses de 6 90 1 c'est le seul
synodaux que ça pourrait être s'écaille
nta terium sauf qui ressemble pas du
tout à sa ktm kenta terium il a il a des
grosses défenses en fait c'est c'est un
corps c'est un peu le corps qu'il
représente mais avec les jambes plus
plus érigé et il aurait voilà une grosse
tête de castor voilà il ressemblerait ça
ça me semble assez fidèle ça comme
représentation y aura une grosse tête de
castor parce que les cailles nta terium
il avait des grosses des grosses incisif
comme des rongeurs
donc c'est pas du tout le synodaux qu'il
nous montre et d'ailleurs ça aurait été
un herbivore pas un carnivore kalenda
terium il ya des grosses dans des
grosses dents car et voilà
karine terium il ya des grosses dents de
prix t-il aux antilles d'écart et donc
serait pas du tout et est un carnivore
comme nous le montre sur la terre des
dinosaures kaita terium c'était un
herbivore quoi bon là en l'occurrence ce
doit être ligot qui fut sous treaty
l'odon c'est une famille où ils ont tous
la même tronche laiterie thilo d'anti
des donc on peut prendre l'un pour
l'autre sans aucun problème mais voilà
ce que je veux dire c'est que je ne sais
pas quel est le synode ondes qu'ils ont
choisie comme modèle je suis quasiment
sûr que ces tri nations mais si c'est le
cas c'est une erreur gigantesque de 30
millions d'années quoi et en plus il est
trop gros
voilà petit voilà là on voit deux
postaux sus en train de se de ce
d'essayer de s'impressionner là l'autre
comportement qui est repris directement
des espèces modernes je veux dire on
n'en sait rien si les postes sus il
venait il faisait vraiment ça mais du
coup c'est pareil ça vaudrait le coup de
le dire ça ça peut être 10 a même pas
besoin d'être montrées on peut dire
voilà les carnivores modernes font ça
les carnivores du passé font ça ouais
bon là il ya postaux sus en train de
pisser voile avec pour marquer son
territoire
est ce que est ce qu'on connaît des
archosaures qui font ça aujourd'hui
pisser pour marquer son territoire je
vais dire ces fameux personnellement ça
m'évoque un comportement qui est
essentiellement malien quoi pis c'est
pour marquer son territoire
donc bon est-ce que les post suc us
voilà est-ce que est ce qu'on a déjà vu
des archosaures peas et pour marquer
leur territoire je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas que les archosaures il s'est
pas tellement l'odorat qui le qui est
leur sens principal généralement assez
plutôt enfin exception faite de
d'espèces comme un tyrannosaure comme
les tyrannosaures par exemple qui ont
des bulbes olfactifs très développé les
volets vautours aussi on a nos doha très
développée mais je veux dire il ya des
espèces par ci par là mais globalement
c'est plutôt la vue qui est le caractère
fall eux le sens l'organe d'essence ne
plus utiliser chez les archosaures c'est
globalement la vue et le toucher chez
les crocodiles quoi c'est pas tellement
le l'odorat quoi déposer déposer des
démarques sensorielle des marques
olfactives c'est plutôt un truc de
mammifères parce que chez les mammifères
l'olfaction c'est vraiment un gros truc
et là par contre on n'a que quelques
exceptions comme les mammifères marins
et les primates
ça c'est les exceptions les espèces qui
ont un sens olfactif
- développer maintenant on voit nos
fameux 6,90 en train de bouffer leur
bébé en train de bouffer leur
progéniture c'est mignon mais c'est
pareil y'a jamais eu la moindre preuve
de ce genre de comportement là on notera
quand même que ce s'est pas fait en
images de synthèse donc c'est moins
dégueulasse que le reste c'est pareil on
voit un terrier pour un couple mais on
n'a jamais trouvé de couple de sinnoh
d'hondt dans un terreau hier c'est
pareil dans les couples dans l'est dans
les terriers ans généralement on trouve
ainsi nos deux seules ou pas de sinnoh
donc du tout dans ce cas là c'est dur
d'attribuer à qui appartient le terrier
ou alors on trouve des associations
adultes juvénile mais rarement très
rarement on trouve des couples entre
guillemets d2 synodaux adultes dans un
terrier donc ça c'est pareil même la vie
en couple des 6 90 on pourrait en
discuter
il est même fort probable qu'il n'est
pas vécu en couple du tout pour ainsi
dire en tout cas les preuves sont
manquantes
voilà le silo physis trouva d'hypnose et
ça c'est assez intéressant parce que
effectivement on sait que les digues ne
l'est aujourd'hui s'enferme dans des
sacs remplis d'eau et sans terre dans
des terriers pour échapper à la
sécheresse et on a des terriers qui
contiennent des dents de d'hypnose de
fossiles depuis le dévot n'y a je crois
on en a dans le permien et on en a dans
le trias donc on sait que l'équipe ne se
faisait ça ça par contre je suis
d'accord ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
ça me dire voilà après encore une fois
je ne suis pas sûr que que les contenus
stomacaux de ces lots physis est révélée
ddd fragments de deux types neste mais
bon
encore 2 euros pièce
la big up big up au marionnettiste parce
que là c'est vraiment la vision d'en
faire la tronche du post au sus c'est un
truc de malade donc là cette scène est
intéressante parce qu'elle montre
justement laisser l'eau physis en train
de se rassembler voyez là de tout le
troupeau est là il est en train de se
rassembler et c'est pas forcément un
comportement social
donc ça montre aussi que l'école et
c'est l'office
enfin que les carnivores peuvent être
rassemblés sans pour autant qu'il y est
vian troupeau donc pas ce que laissait
l'office
ils ont été trouvés en groupe le premier
les premiers groupes de ces lots physis
enfin le premier fossile de ces lots
physis ont été retrouvés en groupe dans
un ranch je crois qu'elle s'appelle le
ghost ranch
donc voilà le ghost voilà laisser l'eau
physis d'hugo strange voyez c'est un
gros assemblage de celle au physique il
y en a dans tous les sens là c'est des
squelettes empilés les uns sur les
autres
donc voilà ce que ça donne en gros si
vous regardez ça de avec un oeil
interprétatif quoi donc les premiers
c'est l'office ils ont été retrouvés en
groupe mais ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils vivaient en troupeau mais ce
qu'il ya de marrant en fait c'est qu'il
ya quasiment pas de là quasiment pas de
controverse autour de la vie en troupeau
chez ces lots physis alors que par
contre est-ce que les raptor est ce que
les dés nonick us chassé en troupeau ça
par contre c'est un gros sujet de
controverse et ça c'est pareil ça vous
avez totalement le reflet de la culture
populaire les seules au physique on s'en
fou alors que les raptor basse et les
raptors
voilà c'est l'erap torse et jurassic
park alors il faut savoir s'il chasser
en meute ou pas c'est le physique on
s'en fout ça pourrait être voilà cet
assemblage pourrait être un assemblage
qui a été provoquée par une crue voilà
donc ça à concentrer des maccabées
complètement artificiellement où il
aurait très bien pu vivre et mourir
ensemble où il aurait très bien ne pas
forcément vivre ensemble mais se
retrouvait fossilisés ensemble à
l'occasion d'un petit festin comme celui
là ce qu'on appelle à un piège à
prédateurs voilà donc vous avez un truc
qui crèvent à un endroit et puis les
autres qui s'accumulent par dessus et
puis pour peu que l'endroit ce soit des
des sables mouvants ou bien quelque
chose d'un peu pas forcément des sables
mouvants mais un marais enfin un truc
dans lesquelles les carnivores se
retrouveraient piégé bah du coup hop ça
fait plus ça attire plus de carnivores
et ainsi de suite les carnivores
s'attire les uns les autres et plus on
accumule de la charogne et plus ça
attire du monde et plus il ya du monde
qui se retrouve coincé dans le marais et
ainsi de suite quoi donc ça peut aussi
être un piège à prédateurs une
concentration de carnivores donc il faut
faire attention faut faire très
attention aux interprétations trouver
des animaux trouvés un empilement
d'animaux morts
ça vous montre que les animaux
sont morts empilées ça veut pas dire
qu'ils vivaient en piles et voilà et
puis j'en veux pour preuve c'est laisser
le truc que je montre à chaque fois mais
à chaque fois vous allez voir l'article
cooked tout def koup'tou def
aino voilà vous allez voir cet article
donc rayno koukoudf qui a été publiée
dans plos one voilà il ya 10 millions
d'années il ya un rhinocéros qui s'est
retrouvé coincé dans une coulée de lave
voilà il ya un crâne de rhinocéros qui
est retrouvé dans une coulée de lave
vieilles de dix minutes de 9 et quelques
millions d'années et donc bah si vous
faites une interprétation stricte de ce
que vous voyez ça voulait dire que le
rhinocéros y vivaient dans la lave
voilà et c'est pas le cas ben c'est
pareil avec les assemblages de
carnivores si vous trouvez plein d'arnie
de carnivores empilés les uns sur les
autres
ça veut pas forcément dire que les
carnivores ils vivaient ensemble
ça veut dire qu'ils sont peut-être mort
ensemble ou que du moins ils se sont
retrouvés fossilisés ensemble et ça
c'est une interprétation qui est assez
différente
donc voilà vous avez le crâne de
rhinocéros dans le tuf basaltiques très
net voilà faut faire attention c'est ce
qu'on appelle une thanatos et n'osent
c'est un assemblage formé par former
durant l' amorce et les thanatos
haineuse ne reflète pas forcément les
biocénose et puis comme ça vous pouvez
retrouver plein l'uci qui tombe de
l'arbre
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez lucie
falling from three voilà si vous vous
rappelez de cette image qui était à ses
glorieuses de l'uci qui tombe d'un arbre
et qui du coup se fracture se fracturent
les jambes fracturé les bras et tout ça
on retrouve des fractures sur le corps
de lucie bon qui déjà
n'est peut-être pas forcément 100% un
seul individu mais bon passons pas sont
là dessus mais on retrouve des fractures
sur le corps de lucie et puis on en
déduit que l'uci se péter la tronche des
arbres et ce
se péter la tronche des arbres et que du
coup ça veut dire qu'elle vivait dans
les arbres bah non c'est une planète au
semnoz c'est
voilà les fossiles sont cassés ils ont
plus qu'assez de mille façons
différentes
mais ça on en a parlé dans une autre
vidéo déjà donc je vais pas revenir
là-dessus mais les autres ont plus
qu'assez de feu de mille façons
différentes et puis dans l'absolu ça
peut aussi vouloir dire que l'uci était
très mauvaise à vivre dans les arbres vu
qu'elle s'est pété la gueule et
évidemment les ichthyosaures qui
accouchent c'est pareil hein les
ichthyosaures qui accouchent c'est aussi
une planète au semnoz ça veut pas dire
que forcément les ichthyosaures à
coucher quand il était vivant ça peut
aussi vouloir dire qu'ils étaient très
mauvais du coup à accoucher donc à
donner vie sans sens pondre neuf voilà
faut faire très attention aux
interprétations qu'on fait
après je dis pas je dis pas que ça veut
dire que les ichthyosaures données pavie
à des des petits qui est enfin n'était
pas vivipare enfin ovovivipare je dis
pas que ça veut pas dire que les
ichthyosaures elle n'était pas aux
visites par et je dis pas que ça veut
dire que lucie n'était pas arboricole je
dis juste qu'il faut se méfier
voilà et que les choses peuvent être
interprétées de façon différente en
particulier quand il s'agit d'une de la
façon dont les fossiles sont agencés
voilà si vous n'avez pas une posture de
vie fossilisés ou si vous n'avez pas par
exemple des empreintes ou des crottes
qui sont pour le coup des fossiles qui
ont été faits par des animaux vivants et
ben eh ben c'est difficile d'interpréter
fossiles interpréter un squelette sait
interpréter un animal mort interpréter
des empreintes sait interpréter les
restes d'un animal vivant
donc il vaut mieux se baser sur les
empreintes canton à faire des cantons
veut faire des hypothèses sur biologique
plutôt que sur des plutôt que sur des
squelettes donc la voile à vivre en
troupeau c'était surtout ça c'est la dc
de fusil s'ils sont en troupeau et ce
qui est bien c'est que du coup ils ne
disent pas qu'ils ont chassé en troupeau
mais qu'ils se sont rassemblés pour
profiter d'une même carcasse ce qui est
ce qui pour une fois est
et un peu plus prudent et puis ça change
voilà de dire on sait qu'à ghost ranchi
sont ils ont été retrouvés ensemble ça
veut pas forcément dire qu'ils vivaient
en troupeau voilà c'est comme tout à
l'heure on a vu le post au sus kyi qui
n'a pas bouffer systématiquement les
places et arias juste parce qu'ils les
avaient devant le nez voilà les
carnivores c'est pas juste des monstres
à chasser c'est les carnivores ils ont
aussi une vie à côté du fait d'être
carnivores et donc oui ça c'est notre
fameux crâne de postaux su ce qui
ressemble à rien enfin le revoilà quoi
je veux dire je l'art là en plus on a
une nouvelle perspective dessus non
attendez je vais essayer de le remettre
je vais essayer de le remettre là parce
qu'on a une nouvelle perspective dessus
on voit un petit peu mieux de quoi il a
l'air voilà là on voit bien narines fo
santé orbitaire orbite
où est le reste voilà vous comparez à
posto sus skull à ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'on regarde qu'est ce qu'on
regarde la narine fo santé orbitaire
orbite narines fo santé en biterre
orbite en plus la forme même pas bonne
quoi je dire donc on a bien la crête là
sur le dessus ça je suis d'accord
d'après le reste c'est aux fraises
c'est au fraysse total je sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs il s'était c'était
tellement simple de prendre
cre enfin un moulage d'un crâne de
postaux sus pourquoi vous avez fait ça
quoi pourquoi vous avez fait ce crâne
dégueulasse je ne comprends pas les
dinosaures saft économiser l'eau de leur
corps alors je suis d'accord tout à
l'heure on a vu le post ou sus en train
de pisser des flots de des flots de
peace assez ahurissant c'est vrai que
dans un clip dans un contexte de climat
aride
ça semble un peu con de balancer des
litres de flotte
on peut on peut imaginer que ces lots
physis avait déjà une piste ultra
concentré comme celle des oiseaux
donc voilà qui pissaient des cristaux
durée vu que vu que techniquement il son
jeu mais pose parce que là il ya un truc
intéressant qui se passe vu que
techniquement ils sont plus proches des
oiseaux que les post chute sucu ça
pourrait être le cas mais bon c'est
pareil encore une fois on nous dit pas
d'où ça sort on ne dit pas pourquoi on
nous dit même pas en quoi ces lots
physis serait plus adapté à la
sécheresse je veux dire en tout ce qu'on
voit c'est un petit animal hyperactif
je suis désolé mais un petit animal
hyperactif c'est pas forcément plus
résistant à la sécheresse quoi info
c'est pas ça qui le rend plus résistant
à la sécheresse
c'est probablement la qualité de sang de
son urine donc là ça aurait été
intéressant justement de voir à quoi
ressemble l urine de celle au physique
comparé au karcher de pistes que nous a
fait le post au suc us tout à l'heure
quoi mais c'est clair que la quantité de
peace qu'à balancer post ce sujet c'est
pas vraiment cohérent avec le fait qui
vit dans un climat aride
donc là on voit ces lots physis en train
de
manger c'est petit et ça ça vient
justement du gisement de ghost ranch
donc le gisement de ghost brunch je
pense que si si je mets juste ghost
ranch cannibalise hommes gouttes mal
écrit j'ai mal écrit cannibalisme mais
voilà ils vont peut-être nous montrer
justement de ces corps de celle au
physique qui contient dans sa cage
thoracique qui contient un bébé c'est
l'office et donc ça se joue peut-être
pas si voilà donc là il ya celle au
physique qui contient un petit c'est le
physique à l'intérieur je suis pas sûr
mais bref c'est de là que ça vient à
l'idée que le laisser l'eau physis était
cannibale ça vient du gisement de ghost
ranch donc ghost ranch d'ailleurs qui se
situe aux argos 30 j'ai d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant fin ça a été que ça a été
remis en question évidemment le fait que
voilà c'est ce fossile
c'est ce spécimen là qui contient des
restes d'un petit d'un petit selo physis
alors apparemment ça a été contestée et
certaines personnes disent que
en fait c'est un crocodile au mof et pas
du tout un [ __ ] physique donc ce sera
un bébé crocodile au mof un bébé proches
parents des ancêtres des crocodiles
voilà qui se serait fait bouffer par un
c'est le physique c'est pas un bébé fait
le seul office is en fait bon c'est
discuter c'est discuter mais ceci dit au
moins il ya des preuves
c'est dommage de ne pas les montrer mais
au moins il ya des preuves de sa sujette
à interprétation comme toute forme de
preuve
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir ou ghost ranch est situé parce
que je me rappelle c'est sensé censées
se dérouler en arizona ce cet épisode
sur la terre des dinosaures là alors que
ghost ranch
bah ça se situe au nouveau mexique voilà
donc en plus c'est même pas genre je
veux dire sachant que l'épisode est
principalement basé sur l'arizona
pourquoi pourquoi
enfin sachant que cet épisode est
principalement basé sur ses lots physis
pourquoi ne pas parler du
nouveau-mexique justement pourquoi ne
pas se faire dérouler l'action à agos
trench justement je sais pas c'est
encore une drôle d'idée j'ai envie de
dire mais bref
donc voilà on voit du cannibalisme
et puis pourquoi pas j'ai envie de dire
pourquoi pas après tout il ya des
preuves pour une fois il ya des preuves
ça aurait été intéressant justement de
les montrer houdan ou encore une fois de
les évoquer voilà dans les commentaires
donc là on voit ainsi nos doutes en
train de chasser et chasse pendant la
nuit
bon je rappelle qu'à cette époque là il
y avait surtout des treaty l'odon idées
en amérique du nord donc enfin en termes
de sinnoh dont donc pas des carnivores
mais l'idée en fait de montrer le dis si
nos deux le petit synodaux en train de
chasser pendant la nuit c'est pour faire
du ces pour anticiper l'évolution future
des destino d'autant mammifères c'est à
dire que les premiers mammifères ils
sont passés par ce qu'on appelle le
nocturne bottleneck donc là un mode de
vie nocturne qui alors l'image classique
c'est le mammifère le petit mammifère
nocturne qui survit aux dinosaures parce
qu'il est nocturne est tout petit et qui
du coup vie à l'ombre des dinosaures
discrètement attendant son heure
voilà donc hélas c'est typiquement ce
qu'ils veulent montrer la cdu vorsah
doing en fait de ce qui va de ce que va
devenir l'évolution des mammifères
pendant le reste du règne des dinosaures
non aviens évidemment voilà alors la big
up big up au réalisateur qui a
probablement soit attendu qui est une
vrai flash flood qui se déclenchent soit
ramené une énorme citerne dans pour
faire une inondation mais là du coup
c'est pas des images de synthèse donc
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
ils sont quand même donner les moyens de
2,2 de simuler une une inondation rapide
et oui qui n'est que de 3 e du coup
parce qu'il n'avait pas encore découvert
le caliente à terium essais et ses 32
petits voila voila l'époque il pouvait
pas savoir donc c'est aussi le problème
de ces choses là dedans ces
documentaires lacets qui vous montre des
choses mais comme ils ne justifient pas
ça permet pas de savoir si les
informations sont à jour ou non alors tu
peux toujours regarder ça en disant bah
oui c'est bien c'est ça c'est l'idée et
puis en fait non pas forcément
genre le pire je sais plus dans quel
épisode de la terre des géants où on
voit où on voit un terreau céphale
venimeux en train de but et un liste
rose or or le seul terreau céphale
venimeux qui ait jamais existé enfin que
pour lequel on a des preuves robuste
qu'il était venimeux c'est hugh chambers
siae hugh chambers il y vivait au
permien alors que liste rose aux russes
en tout cas les listes rose aux russes
qui montre est vive au trias donc c'est
des grosses conneries
voilà mais c'est pareil comme ils vous
disent pas ce qu'on regarde et ben à
prout
voilà on comprend rien on va là c'est
juste purement et simplement faux et on
peut pas seul il ya aucun moyen de le
vérifier à la platéosaure alors plutôt
sympa le platéosaure puisqu'il le montre
capable de se dresser sur ses pattes de
derrière ce qui était probablement le
cas mais platéosaure on sait aussi par
les empreintes notamment les empreintes
de grande combe dans le sud de la france
qu'il se baladait sur quatre pattes
essentiellement mais qu'il était quand
même capables de semer morphologiquement
il n'était pas impossible qu'il puisse
se redresser puisqu'on sait qu'il a des
proches parents comme maçon ce pont dit
luce qui était même franchement bipèdes
donc et puis là l'idée de montrer ses
platéosaure qui arrivent et qui chassent
laisser l'eau physis c'est
c'est de nous faire du teasing pour
l'épisode suivant qu'ils se rassurent
justement les brachiosaures les
diplodocus et tout ça d'ailleurs c'est
l'épisode suivant il y en aurait des
choses à dire sur l'épisode suivant
mais là celui là il est fini et j'ai pas
l'intention de le faire l'épisode
suivant
donc voilà tiens je reviens un peu en
arrière parce qu'évidemment on a eu ce
magnifique plan là sur les plates et aux
orres qui se déplace en troupeau
d'ailleurs mais c'est pareil je crois
pas qu'on ait des embruns des pistes
dans prennent de platéosaure qui
montrent qu'ils se déplaçaient en
troupeau comme ça mais alors ce que
j'aimerais vous montrer c'est pendant le
générique dont j'ai vu qu'ils avaient le
conseiller scientifique qui est passé et
ce petit conseiller scientifique
scientifique advisor voilà c'est
professeur michael benton voilà de
l'université de bristol donc c'est pas
un illustre inconnu du tout un michael
benton à 6 si vous êtes un enfant des
années 80-90 vous prenez n'importe quel
bouquin que vous avez lu étant gamin sur
les dinosaures il ya probablement
michael benton sur la couverture sur la
couverture ou en remerciement quelque
part à l'intérieur ou que michael benton
c'est probablement là d'une des
meilleures autorités auxquelles on
pouvait faire appel pour ce genre de
documentaire donc je pense je pense que
globalement il a fait un bon travail que
les informations pour l'époque était
probablement à jour par contre
par contre le problème c'est qu'il est
directement victimes du format du
documentaire c'est que le format
docu-fiction mélange complètement les
informations scientifiques qu'il a pu
amener et les noix dans un dans un jus
de fiction qui est impossible de
discerner justement des faits
scientifiques qu'il a pu amener donc
voila ca de ça a dû être frustrant
j'imagine pour lui aussi de donner des
informations pour au final pour au final
les voir se faire noyer dans un flot de
de désinformation pour le coup de nom
d'un formation devrais je dire de à flot
de fiction qui qui est indiscernable de
l'information parce que c'est vraiment
ça moi mon problème avec ces
documentaires c'est que oui il ya de
l'info vous avez vous avez probablement
là pendant la demi-heure que ce
reportage à la durée vous avez
probablement l'équivalent de 5 10
minutes de bonne information et c'est
pour ça que je préfère ou youtube je
préfère regarder une vidéo youtube qui
me donnera ses cinq dix minutes
d'informations brutes cash droit dans ma
tronche et sans concession plutôt que de
regarder 30 minutes de sa voire 35
minutes en tout je sais pas combien ça
va durer mais voire 35 minutes de ça et
pas savoir démêler le vrai du faux quoi
là je me suis littéralement happé entre
20 et 25 minutes de da2 comment dire de
fiction voilà il ya 20 25 minutes de
trucs qui servent à rien et si seulement
ça servait que à rien et ça servait
juste à faire joli je vous dirais ok ok
j'accepte j'accepte sauf que c'est pas
ça le problème c'est que ça sert pas
qu'à faire joli ça
insidieusement sa cache la bonne
information
parce que du coup on sait pas ce qui est
le fait et ce qui est la fiction
donc voilà et c'est pour ça que je
déteste faire des bonnes cage
deux reportages comme sur la terre des
dinosaures parce que ça ne sert à rien
voilà ça ne sert à rien c'était pareil
pour premier rhum voilà il ya puis on va
me dire vas voir le jeu c'est bien on va
me dire on va voir le making of
voilà va voir le making of le making of
il explique tout ça il explique d'où
sortent à l'information d'où sort tel
machin parce qu'on me l'a fait pour
premier homme à un premier homme va voir
le making of le making of est vachement
mieux explique tout bas je suis désolé
si le making-of il est vachement mieux
que le documentaire c'était ça qui
aurait fallu qu'ils auraient dû être le
documentaire pas le making of
voilà si le making of est plus
intéressant que le documentaire va
appeler le making of un documentaire
voilà parce que ça suffit
surtout que le making of de premier
homme en l'occurrence il suffit de deux
minutes avant qu'il vous montre une
image d'australopithecus sediba où ils
écrivent en gros dessus aux monnaies les
dites donc même les making of sont pas
dépourvus d'erreur parce qu'évidemment
les making of sont faits un peu plus par
dessus la jambe que le documentaire
lui-même
évidemment vu que moins de monde va les
regarder que bon voilà c'est juste un
petit bonus le making of
donc bon voilà donc oui peut-être que
dans le making of il explique mais je
suis désolé le making off c'est pas le
produit fini 1 c'est c'est comme c'est
comme prometheus ainsi il faut que
j'aille voir les bonus du blu ray pour
comprendre le film le film est mauvais
ben là c'est pareil
s'il faut que j'aille voir les bonus du
blu ray de sur la terre des dinosaures
pour comprendre ce qu'il voulait dire je
suis désolé mais non c'est que le
documentaire est mauvais voilà voilà
dans quel état vous mettez vous vous ne
faites comparer sur la terre des
dinosaures à prometheus vous êtes
content bon et bien sur ce je vous dis à
bientôt pour une pour un nouveau débat
engagé pénitence et une nouvelle ère de
souffrance merci à tous
non en fait je vous remercie pas tiens
et puis pour la peine je vais aller voir
nos knock avec keanu reeves voilà au
moins ça va me détendre je vous déteste
ciao